[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
your duty your constitutional duty is as
jurors to presume kim potter
innocent not not guilty innocent the
jury deliberates the fate of an
ex-minnesota cop as the trial for kim
potter is coming to an end and president
trump files a lawsuit against new york's
attorney general in an attempt to end an
investigation into the trump
organization plus a light at the end of
the tunnel as the jury deliberates in
the months-long trial of former theranos
ceo elizabeth holmes then later will a
jury convict gallane maxwell on federal
sex crimes after she and jeffrey epstein
allegedly groomed young girls for abuse
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to long crime daily
everybody i'm jesse weber in for brian
buckmeyer joined of course with terry
austin we are awaiting a verdict in the
kim potter trial this is the former
officer accused of shooting and killing
dante wright during a horrible traffic
stop last year now or early this year i
should say now this is a case where the
deliberations began on monday the jury
deliberated for about five hours before
they were dismissed for the day and then
they reconvened tuesday morning now
potter faces manslaughter charges
stemming from the shooting death of
wright in april she and an officer in
training pulled right over for an
expired tag when they determined that he
had a warrant for a weapons charge they
attempted to take him into custody body
cam footage shows the struggle and
that's when potter shot him in the chest
wright's car sped off and he died as a
result of his injuries throughout the
trial the jury has heard from several
key witnesses wright's mother father and
former girlfriend all took the stand as
well as the officers that potter worked
with that day and the defendant herself
on monday we heard closing arguments
from the prosecution and the defense
special prosecutor aaron eldridge walked
the jury through what happened on april
11th by playing the body cam footage
frame by frame
pinpointing moments where potter used
her weapon saying that the former cop
ignored the weight and the color of her
firearm eldridge told the jury to focus
on what this case really is about
this case
is not about dante wright
dante wright is not on trial
he's not the reason we're here today
so whether or not you agree with his
decision to flee
is not
what this case is about
he's not the defendant here
this case is about kimberly potter
we're here today because of her conduct
her choices and her actions
we're here today because she killed
dante right
but this case is also not about
the defendant's
law-abiding or peaceful nature that you
heard about
members of the jury good people can
commit crimes
police officers can commit crimes too
and from there the defense took over to
finalize their case refocusing all of
the attention and blame on dante wright
saying he is to blame for everything
that transpired that day
the causation
was donkey right
when
kim potter said
taser taser taser that's a signal for
the law enforcement officers to take
their hands off them which they did
and then a second later she shot him
tragically
but she didn't know she had a gun either
and then he said you shot me
and being alone
what does he do does he stay there and
say hey help me out he takes off then
and you see the video he goes like a jet
he drives a day he's shot he drives to
endanger him he really wanted to get
away and make no mistake about it ladies
and gentlemen this is a most important
affair in my client's life ten years
from now
when you look at yourself in the mirror
and you say by golly
i did the right thing
when i found kim potter not guilty
all right so let's break this down
joining us of course terry austin and
criminal defense attorney taylor coss so
let's get right into it terry i got to
talk to you about the defense because
they're saying that this was a mistake
but that she was justified in shooting
right nonetheless
even if she didn't know it at the time
does that defense make sense to you
it does not i mean therein lies the
problem with the defense's theory
they're arguing that the use of force
was justifiable whether she had a gun or
whether she had a taser they're saying
potter feared for the lives of the other
officers and they're arguing that that's
why she pulled out a weapon but they
can't say it was an accident too you
can't have it both ways and if you think
about it when she pulled out that weapon
there's no question that after the fact
she felt as though it was not justified
just roll the video and it speaks for
itself that was an accident
right
taylor i'm confused because the
prosecution is saying that mistake is
not a defense and that's why you have
recklessness and criminal negligence but
are they right should the jury not
consider mistake as a defense
so i think you know the elements of
these crimes are different than the
normal crimes that we're used to hearing
about you know the the words we usually
hear the key words are intent right
intent conscious objective purpose but
here we're really talking about
recklessness and negligence and so i
don't think oops it was a mistake is a
full defense which is why
i think they're trying to bifurcate
their defense in two different ways on
one hand feel bad for my client feel bad
for her she made a mistake but on the
other hand listen yeah understanding she
made a mistake she was justified
yeah
yeah it's an interesting case and again
we are awaiting a decision which way or
another the jury's going to go but i
want to switch gears right now to the
east coast because police believe the
so-called shopping cart killer could be
responsible for the murders of more than
four women in virginia
thirty-five-year-old anthony robinson is
in jail accused of murdering two women
now police in fairfax county virginia
believe he's responsible for the murders
of two women whose remains were found in
alexandria last week charges are also
expected in those cases police say that
robinson met the two women he's charged
with killing on a dating site and
surveillance video connected him to the
women detectives showed a photo of a
shopping cart used to wheel one victim
to a wooded area
we need to act right now with our law
enforcement partners to figure out who
else our killer has had contact with
and what's his mo
dating sites
motels
blunt force trauma
shopping cart final resting place
he's killed
four already and we we suspect that that
he has more victims
now robinson has lived in maryland and
new york and now they're trying to track
his history to determine if there are
other possible victims still ahead on
lawn crime daily we are also waiting for
a verdict after weeks long of testimony
in the trial of theranos ceo elizabeth
holmes but first former president trump
claiming new york's attorney general
abused her position to investigate the
trump organization details on his new
lawsuit up next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
and welcome back to long crime daily
everybody former president trump has
filed a lawsuit against new york's
attorney general all in an effort to
stop an investigation into his company
this week the trump administration trump
organization i should say in its
namesake sued new york attorney general
leticia james asking a federal court to
stop her ongoing investigation this
comes as james's office seeks to have
the former president sit for a
deposition as part of a civil
investigation in the into the trump
organization trump's lawsuit accuses
james of misconduct saying she abused
her power to investigate by targeting
political rivals james responded to the
lawsuit in a statement saying in part
quote neither mr trump nor the trump
organization get to dictate if and where
they will answer for their actions our
investigation will continue undeterred
because no one is above the law all
right let's talk about this so terry
over to you former president trump
calling the investigation
unconstitutional a violation of his
rights does this have teeth
actually jesse i do think it has some
teeth i mean the question is whether or
not he's got enough evidence to prove it
he's trying to argue that she violated
his rights by pursuing this
investigation it's an abuse of her power
she's just trying to advance her career
and you know basically he's saying that
she's going after him and she has no
right to go after him but i do think she
has plenty of evidence to show that you
know he has been
breaking the law and the only thing i
would advise her he is claiming that
she's speaking publicly and i do think
whether you're you know a state attorney
general or u.s attorney general that's
one thing you should probably try to
avoid speaking on talk shows
well taylor is there a conflict here is
there a conflict that there's james
silvo probe and then an ongoing criminal
investigation by the manhattan da's
office that's happening simultaneously
so i don't think there's a conflict of
interest in fact oftentimes as i know
they're doing in this case the two
agencies work together
in fact my understanding is that several
members of the state attorney general's
office are actually transferred over so
to speak to the da's office now to
cooperate share information and help
work on the criminal side so i don't
think there's a conflict of interest on
that end the one thing i would say is
it's interesting here that trump shares
an interesting bed fellow here because
andrew cuomo
also made these allegations against the
sitting state attorney general so very
rarely do you see cuomo and trump on the
same side but you do on this case
right
yeah i don't know if former president
trump wants to be compared to andrew
cuomo but that's a separate conversation
for a separate time but yeah it makes
interesting bedfellows nonetheless let's
switch over now to georgia and we focus
on the three men who were convicted of
killing ahmad arbury because now they
face an upcoming federal hate crimes
trial and the judge in that case is
actually extending the area where
potential jurors might be selected from
so as you know that travis mcmichael
william roddy bryan and gregory
mcmichael were convicted november 24th
for hunting down and shooting unarmed
black jogger ahmad arbury in 2020 the
three were all found guilty of felony
murder among other charges each of the
men faced life in prison for those
charges a sentencing hearing is set for
january 7th about a month later a
federal trial is scheduled to begin and
it is going to focus on potential hate
crimes in the killing of a mod arbory
new evidence is expected in that trial
including facebook posts and videos that
have never been seen before at a short
hearing monday federal judge lisa godby
woods said that around a thousand people
from across 43 counties will be summoned
as potential jurors and that trial is
set to start february 7th
coming up on long crime daily a former
ceo waits to learn what her fate will be
by a jury i'm talking of course about
the trial of elizabeth holmes and the
federal fraud charges that she
ultimately faces
but first and up next a jury is working
to make a decision on whether delane
maxwell is guilty of sex crimes we're on
verdict watch in her federal trial
[Music]
welcome back everybody the autopsy of a
former nfl player is revealing more
about his death while in police custody
and this independent examination is
revealing evidence of strangulation
former new orleans
saints defensive lineman glenn foster jr
died december 6 while in police custody
in alabama two days later foster was
arrested for a speeding violation he was
released december 5th but later rebooked
minutes later on other charges foster
was found unresponsive in the back of a
police car after arriving at a hospital
and then died the next day a statement
from the family's attorney reads in part
quote keeping people in your custody
alive is literally the lowest bar we can
set for a law enforcement agency foster
played with the saints in the 2013 and
2014 season
and we're on verdict watch in the case
of former silicon valley ceo and
businesswoman elizabeth holmes last week
jurors heard closing arguments from both
sides the prosecution argued that holmes
had the chance to be honest about her
company's blood testing but say she
chose to defraud investors the defense
countered saying the government's case
didn't give the full story they said
there were some quote missing witnesses
and the case was more complicated than
the prosecution said holmes defense team
doubled down on their argument that she
did not intend to defraud investors
holmes faces 11 counts of felony fraud
and conspiracy for allegedly ripping off
investors and potentially endangering
the lives of patients holmes company
therapeutics was once touted as a
company that would revolutionize blood
testing but later tests found that many
issues with the company's technology if
convicted holmes could face 20 years in
prison and a fine of 250 000
plus restitution so terry let me start
with you how do you think her taking the
stand which she did in this case is
going to affect the jury's deliberation
i actually think it helped her case i
think jurors always want to see what
does the defendant have to say and
usually you don't want to put them on
but she's very charming it's how she was
able to actually convince all of these
high-powered investors to invest in her
company and based on reports it does
seem as though she held up fairly well
on cross-examination i just think she
shouldn't have pointed the finger at
sonny balwani because it did make it
seem like she was reaching for straws
but other than that i think it probably
helped her case
the ceo and a person she had a
relationship with taylor what is the
legal line there between making bad
business decisions and fraud
so it really comes down to your actions
you know there are mistakes and there
are bad business judgments and then
there are intentional acts that someone
undertakes to defraud investors so for
instance um you know her defense
attorney say that wasn't her intent and
yet how do you explain for instance her
placing a pfizer logo on top of a report
that pfizer had nothing to do with to
appear that it had the imprimatur of
their approval so those are the
difficult things that she needs to
explain away in order for the jury to go
in her direction
complicated defendant complicated case
we'll wait and see what the jury decides
when we come back we are awaiting a
verdict this is as the jury deliberates
the fate of gelane maxwell in her
federal sex trafficking trial new york
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we head over
to new york now where the jury has
wrapped up its first full day of
deliberations in the gelane maxwell sex
crimes trial
59-year-old maxwell a british socialite
and former companion of jeffrey epstein
faces six felony sex crime charges
prosecutors say she recruited and
groomed young teenage girls for epstein
for sexual abuse if convicted on all six
counts maxwell faces up to 70 years in
prison epstein faced similar charges in
2019 but he was found dead by suicide in
his jail cell before his case went to
trial jurors met for a short time monday
to begin deliberations and they came
back together once again tuesday morning
now long crimes adam asfield has been
following this case closely and was
actually in that courthouse we caught up
with him uh to learn what is the latest
and what is happening in this case
well this is the first full day of
deliberations and on the first full day
of deliberations that we have finally
gotten the jury note requesting evidence
and they are keeping busy they have
requested essentially transcripts of
testimony of all three of glenn
maxwell's alleged victims now there are
four accusing witnesses
one of them is not counted among the
alleged victims they didn't uh request
her transcript because it probably won't
move the needle on the charges one way
or another it was meant to essentially
uh bolster
what prosecutors describe as a pattern
the most significant
thing about the request to me was what
they asked for and what they didn't ask
for they didn't ask for
one of the accusing witnesses
who testified under the pseudonym kate
because a judge instructed them
because she was over the age of consent
at the time she is not an alleged victim
of the crimes charge so it looks like
they are really
getting their hands dirty they are
really engaging with the evidence that
they saw at trial
now it should be noted that the jury was
instructed on whether or not maxwell was
willfully blind to what was going on and
if she was really epstein's number two
as a lot of witnesses have testified so
let's break it down now terry here's
what's interesting if the jury doesn't
believe one of the accusers does that
mean that they don't believe all of the
accusers after all they wanted the read
back of several of the accusers of the
women who spoke out well that's a
distinct possibility sometimes jurors do
look at all of them as if they were the
same and if he or she did something
against one victim he or she did
something against all of them or none of
them but i think we have seen in the
past jurors who do try to look at these
survivors separately and they try to
gauge the credibility of each witness
for themselves and so we've seen that in
the past say for instance in the
weinstein case we know that some of
those victims to get the guilty against
weinstein and others got not guilty
against him so we know it's happened and
jesse you and i covered the kellen
winslow case we know that in that case
it was also split so hopefully the jury
is looking at each of these victims
separately and judging them based on
their credibility and based on their
facts
taylor i have to ask you the prosecution
promised a certain kind of case and we
actually thought this trial was going to
be much longer than it was
do you think the prosecution put forward
in the end as strong as a case as they
ultimately promised
i think that's you know being a former
prosecutor that is one of the biggest
mistakes you can make and one of the
biggest mistakes you can make is promise
something you can't deliver and by
promising a large production listen the
jury's listening that's what they expect
so the question here is is did they meet
the bar did they decide part of the way
through the trial that wait we don't
need all the witnesses we thought we did
everything is going great in our way the
problem is is they have to communicate
that in their summation and closing
arguments to the jury and if you're the
defense side you get right up there and
say remember all those promises they
made you well they didn't keep half of
them how can you find my client guilty
under those circumstances
yeah and terry we have about 20 seconds
again the idea that these women
are lying about her
what would be the incentive
there would be no incentive and the
biggest issue to me jesse in this case
is why would maxwell help these
individuals to travel to be in certain
places without their parents just that
alone to me and we do know that
conspiracy to travel with these
individuals is part of the claim so i
definitely think that these witnesses
are credible and
you know glenn maxwell shouldn't have
been involved in this at all
well
well she said she didn't need to testify
because she felt the prosecution hasn't
met their burden
tally taylor terry thank you so much
really appreciate it thank you everybody
out there for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you